okay hi there
welcome back after a bit of a hiatus for
another
uh q a about science and technology
history
so let's see we had a bunch of questions
saved up here it's a question from
eudacio
about the history of the computer before
the apple ii
well one thing you have to understand is
computers the idea of a computer that an
individual person would use
was something that didn't really arise
until
sometime in the late 1970s
the the original idea computers that
have been built the first electronic
computers built in the late 1940s
and uh they were things intended for
various kinds of research projects uh
things like the
the eniac built i guess at university of
pennsylvania
and then um the the johnny act the john
von neumann computer built
the institute in princeton kind of the
missions of those computers
which were big room sized devices
the missions of those computers were
primarily various kinds of
scientific research or military
work and a common early objective was
ballistics computations
if you shoot a projectile and it goes in
a roughly parabolic trajectory
it isn't exactly parabolic it's not as
simple as that there's air resistance
there's
rotation of the earth there's all kinds
of other things can you solve the
differential equations to figure out
where the thing will actually end up
and uh that was that was an early use
for those kinds of computers
in the the early computers like the one
that was built at the institute for
advanced study in princeton
um there was a little bit of work that
was done on sort of more
basic science kinds of questions like
people tried to
start working out the digits of square
root of two was it going were they going
to be random or not
things like that and uh they could have
studied
cellular automata a topic i like very
much in a topic that john von neumann
also liked
but i don't think john ron neumann ever
sort of connected those two things
together and i don't think anybody ever
simulated a cellular automaton
on an actual computer at that time or at
least not a not a
any kind of tolerably simple one
i think the there were thoughts back in
like 1950
uh john von neumann was talking about
you know could you do weather prediction
on a on an electronic computer
would it be the case that the equations
that describe the fluid dynamics in the
atmosphere
were easy enough to solve that you could
just do them
on on a computer and get reasonable
results for weather forecasts
before that time weather forecasting was
very much of a
pure look at the pattern of fronts and
winds and so on and make
do things based on sort of the judgment
of meteorologists so to speak
there wasn't kind of a a more
quantitative side to it
and i think there was a hope at the time
i think uh von neumann and charney i
think were the people who
wrote an early paper about weather
forecasting there was sort of the
thought that oh it might just be easy
you might just put in the equations and
you might just be easily able to solve
them and be able to predict the weather
turns out it wasn't easy turns out
weather forecasting
is a complicated art that steadily gets
better
but there are parts of the world where
sort of there are
geographic features and so on that make
it really difficult to do weather
prediction
and there are other places where things
are fairly uniform where you kind of see
the weather
just transporting across the plains or
whatever and it's much easier to do it
but there's been sort of gradual
progress on that but it wasn't a slam
dunk in 1950
as soon as we have the equations on a
computer we can solve it
but so those were sort of some early
uses of computers then
the big one which had been a sort of
pre-use of computers
was for essentially data handling
the original kind of use of punch cards
for the census for example for the us
census back in the early 1900s
those that use of kind of tabulation
was something that uh became kind of
eventually became databases on computers
but that was a big early use of the
mainframe computers that started
emerging uh in the 1950s and early 1960s
but those were kind of early uses for
computers were these kinds of scientific
research
military computations uh data tabulation
things like that
there were a few other kind of funky
uses
like i know the early computers made by
digital equipment corporation
were used to do things like control
stage lighting
for plays and so on those were little
so called well i guess mini computers i
guess that was the pdp
um i don't remember which one maybe
seven
eight maybe i'm not sure um was was used
for those purposes and that was
that was kind of a use that was uh
kind of a a separate branch i i think
there may have also been things used for
um factory control and various kinds of
industrial uses like that
but the idea that one would actually
have a computer that a person would have
and they would just have their own
computer and be able to do things with
it
that was not really an idea that arose
in the early days of computing because
computers were too expensive
and who would ever do that now there
were some things
that um were kind of little
partial approaches to that that uh
for example in um
there was uh these things on televisions
like i think was thing called teletext
in england
cfax maybe in france i don't know
whether there was ever a us system that
did this
they were kind of digital information
systems that
connected to your television and your
television this were this was some
analog television signals so it was a
radio signal
and the radio signal was specifying
every line
on the television image it was
specifying you know how much black and
how much white should be on that line
later also color television but at least
when i was growing up in the uk
there were 405 lines in the television
image it then switched to 625 lines
um the uh there were these different um
standards for transmitting uh signals
on on them on televisions i think in the
us
it's ntsc in um in
the uk it was pal i think
um and the idea of these things was
you're going to
send out in kind of a a radio signal
you're going to
send you're going to have to say what
every frame
every whatever 15 times a second or
something you're you're putting up a new
image on the television and you're kind
of scanning
across these scan lines across the
television
and at each scan line you have to say
how much
you know white or black there is at
every point
and the thing was that outside of the
region where those
scan lines existed so you you'd scan
down the whole 405 lines down the
television screen
but then before you needed to start
re-transmitting the next frame
there was like a couple of scan lines
worth of
extra sort of bandwidth to use and so
the idea was
well let's have some kind of digital
information system
that would be able to pick up the data
from those extra scan lines
and you would have this thing where you
would say okay there's 500 pages of
information that's being
continuously updated and you would click
through
to say i want page 200 or something and
then
it would gradually fill in page 200 as
it found the data for page 200
from the scan lines that it was uh
using from the from the television
signal and so that was kind of a that
was sort of an early place where people
saw
something that looked a little bit like
a computer screen um on their television
so to speak
and uh when was that that must have been
late 1960s i think
um well then
this idea uh you know i'm trying to
remember all the different
branches of kind of the emergence of
personal computers
there was the sinclair zx 80 which was a
kit
computer a lot of the early kind of have
a computer for yourself
were kits which were intended for
hobbyists of various kinds
um there was also the um
that was some let's see there was also
much later
yeah that must have been much later the
the bbc micro which was a
a big project in the uk to sort of uh
get computers out in the world i think
that was significantly later than that
in the us there were companies like
altair
and um there was a a whole sort of
gaggle of people
around the homebrew computer club that
met
in the silicon valley area at the time
the silicon valley area had had
companies in it like
varian associates which was a radar
company that came out of um
kind of work done in world war ii and uh
also i guess hewlett packard
was there as well making uh primarily
uh scientific instruments of various
kinds um
and um there were so there was sort of a
a
slightly emerging tech scene there
and the homebrew computer cub was was
one of the um
kind of fixtures there and i i guess
i've met lots of people who were
involved in that um
uh enterprise when it was going and that
must have been
the mid-1970s and sort of out of that
in this tradition of kit type computers
um i think there was if i remember
correctly
there was some kind of hub of companies
that did that kind of thing in
albuquerque new mexico
that was microsoft's first location
microsoft's first product i think was a
um
a basic interpreter for i think one of
the altair computers
in any case the um so that sort of the
early tradition had been
if you want a personal computer make it
yourself it's kind of
something that you would assemble from a
kit and people would kind of
uh exchange plans for how to do this and
you would buy the components
and put the thing together kind of one
of the things that
came about with steve wozniak and steve
jobs is
apple computer was this idea that it's
sort of a pre-assembled thing that you
could just get i think there have been
other examples of that as well
um but there was definitely an emphasis
on sort of the kit idea
i think the original apple one computer
had a lot of uh
kind of interesting
marketing ideas i think its original
cost was 666 dollars
which turned out to be not so felicitous
in in in terms of the sort of uh um
kind of biblical legends around the
number 666
and so on but um by the time
then uh there was sort of a question uh
the the kind of the the objective was
could you
actually make a computer that people
could use what kinds of software would
people run on it
um those were those were some of the
early kinds of things
i have to say i didn't use personal
computers at that time
i used uh
i i think the first computer that i
personally
um owned was probably an osborne one
and that must have been in 1980
when was that probably in 1981 or 1982
that was the an early portable computer
that was the size of a small suitcase
and it
you know plugged into the wall and it
had um uh
a um a little crt display
and it had um a couple of floppy disk
drives and it ran an operating system
called cpm
which was the the typical early
operating system
of these kinds of personal computers and
um
it was you could use it for word
processing i used it a few times but
honestly i didn't find it that useful
um i had the interesting experience of
trying to actually use it as a portable
computer and that was
um it wasn't uh the suitcase size it
wasn't that portable
but for me for example at that time i
was using
computers that were more kind of the
size of half a room
um they were computers like the um uh
uh well either either computers that
were more of the
sort of scientific mainframe class like
cdc
type computers or later um
computers made by digital the vax 11780
which was a computer
about the size of well it was a
it was a big computer that needed to be
in sort of a special room
and um it kind of stood about um
five feet high or something and it was a
big metal cabinet
that was um uh maybe four feet deep or
something
and it was a kind of a long i don't know
15 feet long or something like that
um and it was kind of um it had uh that
was a computer that had
a few megabytes of memory and it had um
uh big disk drives that um uh
could store a fair amount of memory and
it was uh
a computer that had the ability to run
programs that were bigger than the
physical ram by using virtual memory by
swapping data out onto disk and so on
so i have to say i was not as aware of
kind of really personal computers
until well quite a bit later i suppose
the first
computers that i kind of used as
a kind of uh computer
to be the only user of were
sun workstation computers that must have
been
in 1983 or so
1982 1983 those were computers
that were about uh they were sort of um
well they they had a a big bitmap
display
and they were kind of um oh i don't know
how big are they maybe uh uh maybe
the the the size of a a stack of about
five or six pizza boxes or something um
was the typical actually
some of them also had had sort of boxes
that stood on the side
um but those were kind of the first
computers that that i
used as kind of serious i'm the only
user of this computer computers
um and uh uh
actually yeah i think
um i first saw one of those computers
where i can tell you
quite a bit about the history of those
kinds of computers because i was quite
involved in that because we built
software
our smp system that was kind of released
in 1981
um one of the great interests was
getting it to run on all those kinds of
computers so i interacted with
with most of the companies i would say
that were were building those types of
computers
around that time
well let's see oh we got lots of new
questions
here um
um
let's see there's a question here from
carob about what is the fine structure
constant
and why was dirac so interested in it
well okay so fine structure constant
usually called alpha
has value about 1 over 137 point
something or other
the fine structure constant is most
interesting
in the way that it characterizes the
strength of electromagnetic
interactions so if you have
kind of a um uh
it's kind of a dimensionless number that
characterizes sort of how strong the
forces
associated with electrical processes are
and it's something that originally arose
in things to do with observing atomic
spectral lines the absorption and
emission of light
in discrete at discrete frequencies by
atoms and the
structure constant arose in the uh the
kind of splitting
of um of of lines that might otherwise
have been a single
spectral line a single frequency was
split into multiple frequencies
by an amount that was characterized by
this fine structure constant
but the thing that's important uh more
more fundamentally about it is in
quantum electrodynamics
originally the theory of electrons and
photons the theory
of processes that just involve the
electromagnetic field the
electromagnetic forces and so on
that is the thing that characterizes
kind of the how
uh what essentially the likelihood that
an electron
will produce a photon is or the
likelihood that a photon will interact
with an electron
and so when one sets up feynman diagrams
this kind of diagrammatic
mechanism invented by dick feynman back
in the 1940s
um as a way to represent
kind of the the interaction of electrons
and photons you can say well
i've got an electron and it's going to
uh have an electric repulsion from
another electron
well how does that electric propulsion
actually occur
well in quantum field theory it occurs
by the exchange of some discrete number
of virtual photons
so each electron in a sense virtually
emits
a photon which then virtually is
absorbed by the other electron
and that photon is essentially
transferring momentum from one electron
to the other
and so making it to exert one electron
exert a force on the other electron
and you can kind of work out the full
kind of
uh effect of electromagnetism as well as
the exchange of one photon there could
be the exchange of two photons there
could be exchange of three photons and
so on and
the chance of exchanging that photon is
determined by a whole bunch of
mathematical
computation but everything's multiplied
by
alpha the fine structure constant that
characterizes the chance
of emitting absorbing exchanging a
photon
and so the chance of exchanging one
photon is as
proportional to alpha two photons
proportional to alpha squared three
alpha cubed and so on
and so it tells one that one one tries
to do computations in quantum
electrodynamics
because alpha one over 137 is a pretty
small number
there's at least a decent chance that
you can just
look at the exchange with just a few
photons to get a pretty good estimate
of what the complete amount of
electromagnetic effect is
in some particular system that's a
complicated story because it's known
that the series isn't just
alpha to the power k times some kind of
fixed size number
but the number the coefficient can
increase like square root of k
factorial in kth order and there are
other situations in which the real
expansion parameter is not alpha but pi
squared times alpha
and pi squared is 10 and so it isn't
quite as small
but roughly alpha is the thing that is
sort of the expansion parameter
in the power series of working out the
effect effect and quantum
electrodynamics
okay but if you want to sort of
understand kind of
where does quantum electrodynamics come
from what is the
kind of fundamental source uh what is
the
more fundamental theory which could lead
to quantum electrodynamics
it's a good target to say well there's
this numbering quantum electrodynamics
about one over 137.
let's try and reproduce that number and
in our theory of physics for example
eventually we should be able to
reproduce that number
but nobody really knows at all right now
why that number
has the value it has there's a little
bit we know
because that number is the number you
get
from essentially low energy electrons
low energy photons being exchanged
between electrons
if you say i have a photon and it has a
very very high energy very high
momentum momentum for momentum squared
whatever
a very high uh it's a it's a it's a very
um
it's a okay so photons the the energy of
a photon
is proportional to its frequency uh
photons of visible light
have uh a frequency of around
terahertz and um a bit more than that
and free photons of radio photons have
maybe
you know megahertz to gigahertz million
uh cycles per second to a billion cycles
per second
when you get to things like x-rays and
gamma rays
the the uh frequencies are much higher
and the resolution that you can
uh the the the kind of if you made a
microscope or telescope
with a particular frequency of photon
the
what comes from uh that just
the the the resolution that you can get
with a photon of a certain frequency
depends on the wavelength of that photon
and so
as you get to higher frequencies higher
energies you get to correspondingly
uh smaller wavelengths and so you can
effectively resolve smaller things
so you can think of kind of various
kinds of particle
accelerators as being like things that
produce
well kind of virtual photons so it's a
little bit of a different story
that are very high energy very
high frequency very short wavelength and
it's
that kind of short wavelength
that allows them to kind of resolve
features
of things on a smaller scale so right
now
the highest energy kind of resolution is
around 10 to the minus 19 10
minus 20 meters something like that but
kind of the
the point there is that
as you get to uh
higher sort of that smaller scale of
resolution
okay there's a tricky thing maybe i can
try to explain it's a piece of physics
that has to do with this phenomena thing
called the renewalization group
and here's roughly how it works so
if you imagine
let's see how best to explain this um
when you think about an electron
the the electron always has these
photons being emitted and reabsorbed
all the time there are virtual photons
being emitted and reabsorbed
by any electron anywhere in fact
in the nominal way that you compute how
often that happens it happens infinitely
often
but the kind of trick of renormalization
is to say
well a bare electron we don't know what
a bare electron looks like without any
of those photons
coming out and being emitted and
absorbed and so on
all we know is what a an electron of the
kind that we see which includes all
those photons being
emitted and absorbed and so on looks
like so
even though there might be an infinite
effect of those things
the the bare electron might be
infinitely different than what we see
and all we see is the difference between
those infinities which is the actual
electron we see
but around every electron then there's
this kind of virtual cloud
of photons and electron positron pairs
and all kinds of other things
that are being produced emitted and
absorbed over very short periods of time
and as you kind of try to home in
and look at the electron in more and
more detail with essentially a higher
and higher energy photon
you get to sort of drill in and see see
into that kind of cloud of stuff
and you get to sort of get closer and
closer to the bare electron so to speak
and so that means that the effective
properties of the electron
will actually vary with essentially the
energy the
the wavelength the resolution of the
probe that you're using to probe the
electron
and so one of the things that varies is
this
uh is essentially the this this alpha
parameter which is essentially the
so-called coupling constant the strength
of interaction
when you look at the electron very very
close up
it will seem like it has a stronger
strength of interaction
than it does when you look at it at a
greater distance and
so that is called the the presence of a
so-called running coupling constant
the the fact that when you look at
higher energies you're kind of drilling
deeper into you're looking at higher and
higher resolution
and the electron looks as if it has a
higher charge effectively
as as you probe deeper inside you can
you can roughly think it's not quite
right but you can roughly think oh there
are these things that kind of screen out
the charge of the electron
and you're kind of looking inside that
that shell of screening
to see kind of a higher charge and that
and there's kind of a logarithmic
variation um as a function of
essentially the energy
um what the that is a change of the
effective coupling constant
okay so for quantum electrodynamics the
effective coupling constant increases as
you
as you probe to higher energies one of
the
important things about quantum
chromodynamics the theory of quarks and
gluons
is that it goes the other way around
there's this phenomenon called
asymptotic freedom that was discovered
in 1973
um in which it turns out that
for quarks and gluons when you probe in
at
higher energies in at smaller scales the
effective clapping constant actually
seems smaller rather than seeming larger
and that's very important in the ability
to actually do computations in qcd i
had lots of fun in the late 1970s doing
such kinds of computations
because you can as soon as you're sort
of probing things at high energies
the effect of coupling is small enough
that you can use feynman diagrams and
just
compute sort of terms in a power series
to get estimates of what's going on
but in any case back to what that means
for alpha the fine structure constant it
means that the fine structure constant 1
over 137
that's its low energy value the fine
structure constant actually
runs to larger values as you um
as you uh increase the energy and one of
the things that
people were very excited about at the
end of the 1970s early 1980s
is if you kind of track the running
coupling constant
of quantum electrodynamics and the
running coupling constant of qcd
the two things kind of converge so
it's as if there's sort of a unification
at around 10 to 15 gev
that um uh 10 to 15 ev actually
um is that right oh boy it's been a long
time since i thought about these things
um yeah i think it's 10 to the 15
uh electron volts so that's um
at that energy um so that that's uh
um that's
a million equivalents of a million
proton masses is that right
that let's see i i might be off by a few
orders of magnitude there but
but uh sorry it's a long time i used to
write papers about these kinds of things
i think i last wrote a paper about
these kinds of things and their
relationship to cosmology in 1980
and that neuron may not be with us
anymore that has that data
um but in any case the um the main point
is that these
these coupling constants as you as you
increase the energy
they eventually uh get to be the same
value and people thought that was very
significant
and that was a sign of some sort of
unification that all these different
forces of nature so to speak all these
different um
uh types of interactions were really the
same thing and it was just because we
are
kind of looking at them at low energies
that they appear to be different and
have different effective carbon
constants
so that explaining the one over 137 is a
little bit of a trickier thing because
it really is only one of 137
in this low energy limit that we happen
to be used to looking at
okay so there's a history of people
trying to explain
how one over 137 arises
from some form more fundamental theory
of physics
there was a chap called arthur eddington
um
who uh in the 1920s 1930s i think
was very big on finding sort of a a
fundamental theory of physics
he was also the person who famously uh
went to do the um uh
the observation of a total solar eclipse
in south africa in 1919 i guess
that validated einstein's general theory
of relativity by looking at the
the bending of the additional bending of
light around the sun predicted by that
theory
how accurate that how good that
experiment really was is not
particularly clear
i think there was a a certain degree of
a desire to find a certain result in
that experiment but anyway
arthur eddington's kind of more day job
was studying sort of theoretical aspects
of physics
he was based in cambridge in the uk um
and um he uh
famously had this kind of fundamental
theory of physics that would just
involve numbers
and kind of uh explaining everything
about the universe just by working
things out as a sort of number theory
exercise
though number theory itself wasn't very
popular in those days
and i don't think he described it that
way but famously
he got the result one over 136 for the
fine structure constant
and uh at the time one of 136
was the experimentally observed value of
the fine structure constant
so it's kind of a pattern here of why
i'm a little bit suspicious about the
1919
uh observation and so on because then
what happened is
that the experiments were done more
accurately
and the number really kind of flopped
over to being 137
it looked like it might be exactly that
as a as a reciprocal of an integer
turns out it wasn't exactly that but
that wasn't known at the time and so
famously eddington said
oh he made a mistake in the calculation
uh you need to add
one for the trace of the matrix the
result really should be one over 137
which just wasn't very convincing
because it was one of these things where
uh you know first dividend 136 then 137.
okay why was paul durack interested in
these things
well paul durack was most famous
for the dirac equation and for having
predicted the existence of the positron
the anti-particle of the electron so the
dirac equation originated
in the 1920s i guess
and uh was along with kind of the
general origination of quantum mechanics
in quantum mechanics
sort of the first thing that was
a very kind of quantitatively explorable
thing was schrodinger's equation oh
and schrodinger had this equation that
describes the
uh the the wave function so-called wave
function
that is then interpreted in max bourne's
born interpretation of the square of the
wave function
is the probability and when you make a
measurement in quantum mechanics but the
big point
of the schrodinger equation is that it's
a an equation that looks very much like
the diffusion equation like the equation
for
for sort of the diffusion of a gas
except that it has an
i in it a square root of minus one in it
so it's like a
an imaginary complex diffusion equation
that describes
how this uh kind of a wave function that
represents
in the end the probability of finding a
quantum particle somewhere
um is is going to evolve with time or
in particular if you have a stationary
state
like the analog of of having you know a
string where you
where you have the string fixed at the
ends and you're just sort of uh
bowing the string you're playing a a
string there are certain modes of the
string from the string has just sort of
one
one uh peak in the middle to having two
peaks three peaks and so on
those uh kind of
eigen modes those uh uh
sort of things which are the the
consistent possible solutions to the
equation
given those boundary conditions given
that you've sort of
uh anchored the string at the two ends
the analog of that for the triangular
equation
is things like solving for what will an
electron do
when it's trapped inside a hydrogen atom
when it's trapped by
electrical forces inside a hydrogen atom
what will an electron
do and so solving the schrodinger
equation for that
you can do that and you get out this
whole uh
thing involving lager polynomials and
all kinds of other
nice mathematical constructs but the end
result is
just like you have these discrete
frequencies for a for a plucked string
so you have these discrete energy levels
for electrons in a hydrogen atom
and those were found to be uh more or
less as people observed them
but one of the things about the
schrodinger equation is it describes
the the probabilities probability
amplitudes
for non-relativistic particles for
particles that are going slow compared
to the speed of light
but then the question was well how would
you combine relativity special
relativity
and quantum mechanics how would you
combine those together
how would you deal with particles which
were not going slowly compared to the
speed of light
and that's where paul durak came into
the picture and came up with the dirac
equation
which is an equation of a somewhat
different form that
has the feature that if you have low
velocity particles
it's just like the schrodinger equation
but if you have higher velocity
particles it works differently
and it's an equation which ultimately
describes electrons relativistic
electrons
and it was an equation that has the
feature that
it has both a positive energy solution
and the equation has a sort of symmetry
in it
which means that in addition to the
positive energy solution there's also a
negative energy solution
and dirac wasn't sure quite what to make
of that and realized in the end
that one should think of that as being
the existence of an anti-particle to the
electron
it's a uh it's a little bit more
complicated one thinks of this kind of
uh sea of of electrons that sort of the
filled sea of electrons and there's a
question of
there will be an uh a sort of a a hole
in that filled c that represents the
positron
um the anti-electron so the
anti-electron has a
negative electric charge it still has a
positive mass
that's described by the dirac equation
and the rack equation that was sort of
the
the thing that um dirac was was
particularly famous for
was the the iraq equation and the
prediction
of the existence of the positron that
was observed in cosmic ray experiments
in 19 early 1933-ish i think
um was uh was actually found to be a
real thing just like the electron but
was with opposite charge
so dirac was interested in other kinds
of things he was very much of a
a purist very much of a kind of
minimalist
physicist i never met him unfortunately
i i could have done so but i did not do
so
um my friend dick feynman uh always used
to say that one of the features of dirac
was that he would always give just one
word answers to any questions he was
very
very kind of uh cut and dried
monosyllabic
i think he also was it was very much
more that way when he
lived and worked in cambridge in the uk
when he finally retired cambridge had a
mandatory retirement age
when he finally was sort of retired from
cambridge
he went to work in florida and
apparently he really opened up when he
went there and became kind of a very
a quite social uh cheerful fellow who
would chat with people which he really
hadn't
been doing at all in the past but in his
later years dirac was interested
in the possibility that things like
alpha the fine structure constant
might be things that vary during the
history of the universe
and might be things where as the
universe expands for example the value
of that might change
uh people have thought from from people
like um uh
mark um mark's principle and so on that
maybe
the the the the whole of the universe
has an effect on uh for example that
inertia might be a result of the effect
of
the whole of the rest of the universe on
us here i don't think that's quite the
right way to think about it
but that was a sort of an idea that was
kind of in the air
and dirac had this notion that maybe the
fine structure constant
changes over time and there will be
consequences to that like for example
the size of the sun the size of the
earth would potentially change because
the size of atoms would change
because of that and iraq tried to look
for evidence of those kinds of things
and that was something that i know he
was interested in
i don't think there is evidence of that
um and
uh i personally will be surprised
if uh based on our current ideas about
fundamental physics
i would be surprised if in the current
epoch of the universe if there's a
change in the fine structure constant as
a function of time
as a result of kind of cosmological
effects in the universe
um in the very early universe i think it
will be a quite different story
but i think everybody thinks it would be
somewhat different in the very early
universe
let's see um
oh there's a question here from irish
asking can you recall
any what could have been moments in the
development of computers that could have
taken off
had the right decisions or factors
occurred
well there are so many things i mean
you know i think one of the most
dramatic probably was in the 1840s
uh charles babbage had this design for
his analytical engine
which was a mechanical computer he had
built a difference engine which was a
way of essentially
computing values of polynomials by using
this complicated
gears and cogs type machine that was
actually built
he had this plan for an analytical
engine which would use punch cards
of the kind that jacquard had invented
back in 1800
for controlling uh looms for weaving and
so on
the idea was that that would control the
operations of the computer
of the analytical engine everything in
those days was an engine so to speak
because steam engines were really big in
those days
and so that was something where
uh babbage had kind of this design for
how you could sort of specify an
arbitrary computation
using uh these punch cards and having
all this gearing and things
to do different operations depending on
what the punch card said
and that would have led to that with the
idea was
to make this thing kind of the size of
about
the size of a steam engine actually um
that would be the sort of
giant analytical engine okay so the idea
was
make an analytical engine you'd be able
to do all kinds of computations
babbage was not a particularly good
manager of large engineering projects
and he also was quite obsessed with
getting other people to pay for things
even though he probably could have
actually paid for things because he'd
inherited
a lot of money from his father who was a
banker and then he later was involved in
a startup which was a
um insurance company that i think did
quite well
but anyway he was much more concerned
with getting the british government
to pay for things and they paid for a
bit and they wouldn't pay for more
and he had this friend ada lovelace who
was significantly younger than him
they met i think when she was maybe 17
and he was like 40.
and they uh ada lovelace
was a i think she really saw herself
as much as anything as a potential
expositor of science
she kind of had as a bit of a model mary
somerville who'd been
a translator of laplace's celestial
mechanics works i think
and also a uh a person who had written a
lot of science exposition
and ada lovelace was the the daughter of
um byron the poet
although she never met him um the uh
uh and i think had sort of a a a
proclivity for for writing
but in any case she got
very interested in the difference engine
and later in the sort of plans for the
analytical engine
and in the end when babbage was sort of
describing
the analytical engine uh he only wrote
he wrote one kind of paper that was
originally in
italian i guess that um
had um was uh a description based on
some lectures he gave
of the analytical engine and uh
they were going to be republished in
english
they were translated by a chap who was a
in the italian kind of corps of
engineers later actually became the
prime minister of italy that person did
manabrea was his name um the uh
in any case he um he translated this
and ada lovelace took it upon herself to
write an
introduction to the piece about the
analytical engine by babbage and the
piece about the analytical engine by
babbage is a very engineering
kind of document ada lovelace tried to
describe
a bit more um uh
kind of um uh
in in a sort of broader terms what the
significance of the analytical engine
might be
and and managed to figure out a lot i
mean she really understood
kind of the abstract idea of computation
which i don't think babbage ever did
i think he was very much let's use this
thing to print mathematical tables
that's what it does
and ada lovelace had this very nice
place where she says um the algebraical
engine
uh no the the analytical engine will um
just as the jacquard loom can be
controlled by a punch card to
weave patterns of birds and flowers so
the analytical engine will be controlled
by punch
cards to weave algebraical patterns
which might include things like
algorithmically shouldn't use the word
algorithm
composed music and as well as
mathematics and other kinds of things
so she had pretty good idea of kind of
this general notion of computation
meanwhile babbage was trying to get the
analytical engine uh
built he was trying to get ada lovelace
who he thought was much richer than him
although i don't think it was true in
the end
because i looked at his account books um
and i think he was all his life was
under complete misimpression
that because because ada lovelace was a
countess
she must be much much wealthier than him
he was a mere
uh you know son of a banker type thing
but any case
the um uh
this was um he tried to get ada
to um be kind of a
a fundraiser and to go convince the
british government
and queen victoria and people like that
that
um yes the analytical engine should be
funded by the government
well in fact what ate has said
to charles babbage was look if we're
going to make any progress with this
thing
you've got to let me ada run the project
you're just totally incompetent at
running this project
and there's a wonderful series of
letters that the two of them exchanged
which i had a chance to look at a number
of years ago back in those days
there were like 14 mail deliveries per
day in london and they also had
had people who would deliver mail
between each other so they were they
were doing the equivalent of exchanging
almost text messages
and so you see this going back and forth
in the in the archives that are still
there
of um uh ada sending charles babbage
this um
this letter that basically says you
gotta let me run this project if it's
gonna go anywhere
and charles babbage writes on the letter
you know i refused all her demands
um but then a few hours later he's kind
of recanted
and eventually says some uh
sure you know you can you should run
this project
well unfortunately um ada lovelace got
sick
uh probably with uh with probably
cervical cancer
um and that sort of took her out of
action
and so that never really happened that
way
had it happened what would have occurred
in the history of computing
probably the analytical engine would
have been built probably it would have
been used to compute
well all sorts of things for uh for
astronomy for navigation
for life insurance tables it would have
been kind of a
victorian cloud computing operation and
and that was kind of the idea that that
um
uh ada lovelace and charles babbage had
was kind of that people it would be a
service bureau
where they would operate these giant
analytical engines uh one can sort of
imagine them in london i i think at the
time
they very much imagined them as
mechanical devices
although they were acquainted with
people like uh charles whetstone of of
electrical and and michael faraday also
um and so there was kind of a some
knowledge of
uh electrical devices as well and
perhaps they would have made the jump
to electromechanical devices instead of
uh pure
mechanical devices so that's definitely
one moment in the history of computing
the 1840s might have been the early
cloud computing a very
loud electromechanical cloud computing
but it might have been a
kind of early use of that and it might
have been the case that the things that
ada lovelace figured out about kind of
this abstract theory of computing
might have taken off at that time as it
was they were kind of lost
for 60 70 80 more than that years
nearly 100 years actually and nobody
paid attention to them
and and that was kind of not the path
that things went on
so that was one kind of history of
computing might have been a different
way
i think another one
by the time kind of the origination of
of kind of our modern ideas of
sort of universal computation started
coming around first with moses sean
finkel in 1920
then with kurt gerdel in 1931 alan
turing 1936
alonso church 1935 all these kinds of
things coming in all these different
models of the computational process
all abstract models being invented
essentially for the sake of doing
mathematics and doing logic
i think by that point things
there was not too much that was
dramatically missed at that time
perhaps the one thing that was missed
was combinators invented by moses
shonenfinkel in 1920 the sk
combinators which are things that in a
was sort of the
the original kind of way to do
arbitrary symbolic computation they're
very obscure
you have this whole combination of s of
k of s of s of k of k of k
whatever big long strings of s's and k's
and you
feed them a uh
a symbolic argument and then they have
reduction rules
and you can do any computation with
those reduction rules i studied this a
bunch
towards the end of last year in in
preparation for the
uh centenary of combinators on december
7th of
2020. but combinators
are this way of computing that involves
having symbolic expressions and making
transformation rules for symbolic
expressions
very different from the way of computing
where you say i've got a small
collection of numbers which are stored
in registers and i'm going to
uh sort of do arithmetic operations on
those numbers it's it's a much more
abstracted
much more symbolic version of
computation it's one that i made
uh significant use of when i started
designing first smp and
and then well from language back uh well
40 years ago now
and um but combinators are this
different model of computation that are
still pretty hard to understand in their
raw form
had people understood them back in 1920
and it would have been a huge challenge
to understand them really at that time
because the whole context of
wasn't really wasn't really up and
running at that point
had people understood them they might
have built computers in an
utterly different way and for example
they might have realized as we still
don't know how to do
how to make molecular scale computers
that really can operate with molecular
components
that's something i think much more
plausibly to come from studying things
like combinators
than to study come from studying
collections of of uh
numbers and registers containing numbers
and so on now another
sort of might have been a different way
is that moses schoenfinkel himself
was presented this one lecture about
combinators in 1920
and then in 1924 he'd been in gutting
and working around david hilbert to
famous mathematician um although sean
finkel himself came from ukraine
but in 1924 and we've tracked down the
exact day when this happened
moses sean finkel went to moscow we
still don't know really why
and moses sean finkel disappears from
view
after that time so no idea what happened
to him there are sort of rumors
that he had various psychiatric issues
although
the evidence for that is not
overwhelming but in any case
moses sean finkel sort of disappears
had he not disappeared had he built a
whole giant
kind of career out of studying
combinators
it's possible that the history of
computing
would have been somewhat different and
that we would have seen symbolic
computing and functional programming and
things which are
both features of combinators much
earlier now haskell curry
who kind of picked up on combinators
did not independently discover them he'd
been kind of nosing around the same area
and then in 1927 he found um
a uh uh found
sean finkel's paper in the princeton
university library
and started embarked on a whole career
of studying combinators
although i don't think he really
understood some of the deepest
significance of combinators
as foundational ideas for computing um i
think he he really thought of them
more as something that you did logic
about well actually
that's kind of what i thought was the
case but i've heard from people that
actually haskell curry
when it was first was actually
quite involved during world war ii in
various kinds of
early computer efforts and later in
things related to the aniak and so on
and that he actually i have heard
claimed i don't have great evidence for
this yet
um that he had actually proposed on the
basis
of um uh well of his study of
combinators
and also of the somewhat more
understandable lambda calculus from
alonzo church
that really computers should work by
what amounts to functional programming
and but he wrote these reports and
people just ignored them
and john von neumann who wrote the more
famous
reports on kind of how computers should
be set
up really was pushing the write it like
standard kind of um uh the way we see
low-level programming languages work
today where there are
variables and and numbers
and arithmetic operations on numbers and
program counters and jumps and loops and
things like this
apparently curry sort of basing it on
combinators and a little bit on
under calculus have proposed something
much closer to functional programming
but it didn't happen that way probably
because people didn't understand what he
was talking about at the time
i mean i know that um uh well another
another thing around the same time ken
iverson
developed apl as kind of this notation
and language for doing array processing
another functional programming language
originally developed more as an on-paper
language
than a thing that was actually going to
be implemented on computers although it
was
implemented on computers um ken iverson
kind of made the mistake of having this
sort of
special weird character set that would
be sort of the math
operations of algorithms in apl and apl
just didn't catch on really it caught on
a little bit in some particular parts of
the
financial industry morgan stanley for
example used it
uh quite a lot and and so on and um
i think that the um uh
that was another kind of near miss of
apl not catching on and instead for
example basic
which was much more a uh a sort of a
simple language
based on the kind of very much von
neumann kind of variables and loops
paradigm for programming was something
which
which was used along with fortran and
cobol
and so on which were again in that
tradition there was also the lisp
tradition
that was from john mccarthy in 1958 um
and uh that had kind of come out of uh
church's lambda calculus
and again was something which was not
very widely understood and also
had the problem it was really hard to
implement back in the early days in fact
even when i
started writing systems for doing
symbolic computation
this is now late 1970s it was
not realistic to use lisp there were
systems that
were based on lisp but it was quite
impractical it would just
wouldn't run fast enough on real on
practical computers at the time
to be used as a foundation and although
it had uh uh certain
certain aspects of it where were
mathematically elegant sort of
interesting what happened
there was a certain elegance to the
lambda calculus part of it
but then there were things that didn't
quite work that involved kind of
variables and
and the renaming of variables when you
have nested lambda functions
things like this and it's like then
there started to be these hack towers
and they would think these things about
how you actually did reduction of lambda
expressions and you know what in lambda
calculus would be you know beta
reduction and atom reduction
all these kinds of things how would that
really work in the context of a
practical computer system
and i would say that there was a certain
degree of kind of
uh you know rising tide of clue jerry
that was needed
to make all that stuff work which kind
of downgraded
the otherwise very elegant kind of
conceptual foundation
of what was what was done with with lisp
so there's a couple of things that um i
suppose
you know functional programming could
have come in much earlier the whole idea
of computing could have come in much
earlier
we could have had a very different
foundation for the way that we currently
think about computing
i mean those are a few things another
another thing that um
uh oh there are just there are so many
of these i mean there are so many
detailed things where there were sort of
technology competitions between
different technologies
and where the technology that won one
for
reasons that had to do with either a
detail
or a business uh situation uh
all those kinds of things um that were
almost coincidental
to what one might think of as the kind
of intellectual threat of the
development of computing
um
all right there's a question here
another what if question
from david what do you think would have
happened if archimedes had discovered
calculus in 200 bc
an interesting question
first question is what would he have
used it for
because i think in greek times the
notion
of kind of
things happening as a function of time
which is a large part of the story of
calculus
wasn't so much there it was you know
what's the universe made of
okay it's made of atoms okay maybe it's
made of different kinds of polyhedra put
together
okay maybe there are epicycles and these
epicycles
are crystal spheres and they have
this certain configuration of motions
but it's very much of
what's the thing that's there it's not
how does something change over time
the idea of sort of change over time i
think came in much more
oh by the by 1200 1400 people were kind
of vaguely talking about
almost making sort of space-time
pictures of things
of showing things as a function of time
so to speak
and then galileo for example uh was
was i think very much more into that as
he started talking about motion
and discovering kind of the parabolic
law for
uh you know position as a function of um
of time under uniform acceleration for
example in the earth's gravitational
field
and then by the time newton was in the
game
in 1687 and so on that was a time when
people
were really understanding that we want
to study
things happening through time motion
happening through time
and i think that was a thing that was
for newton
probably that was the story of calculus
newton talked about fluxions
now our x dot notation and things that
was all about
things fluxing things changing in time
i just don't think that notion really
was something that archimedes was
as into i think archimedes was more into
the the sort of the static shapes of
objects so the discovery of calculus
that happened with people like newton um
that is really i think a story of people
being interested in the development of
things in time
now could archimedes have discovered
calculus
as a way to do menstruation to do the
measurement of for example solid objects
archimedes has some pretty good tricks
about
um uh figuring out you know the volumes
of cones
and compared to spheres and things like
that he figured out pretty well
how to work out the um kind of the
volumes of things
and i don't think he had a great need
for calculus in doing that at that time
i think he'd gotten
good enough with his geometrical kinds
of methods to not need that
now subsequently people like kepler this
is way later this is
1600s kepler was
interested in things like the volumes of
solids of revolution
i think capital had a little side
business computing volumes of wine casks
based on their external shapes and uh
that was something that needed sort of a
a pre version of calculus
so i think archimedes wouldn't have
known what to do with sort of time
varying calculus
i think he might have known what to do
he might have been very excited about
oh i can now work out the volumes of
these figures
using calculus rather than using these
geometrical tricks
but i don't think that for example
newton's laws of motion
i don't think that people were kind of
ready yet
for thinking about those sort of time
dependent phenomena at the time of
archimedes
i think that um now
you know in terms of of uh something
which
another what if of computing the
antikythera device
this device that comes from around
between
100 bc and 100 a.d this uh a single
object that we have from that from
antiquity
which is a collection of gears and so on
that is
essentially an astronomical mechanical
computer
that has so some number of tens of gears
in it
it's pretty elaborate computations that
it's doing including things like
estimating when eclipses might occur and
things like this
that was a device that i at least sort
of romantically think
might have been made by or involved with
archimedes
um and i think that an interesting
question is you know maybe archimedes
had a side business
that's a little bit like our business of
making uh
tools for mathematics so to speak and
they might have been
not the calculus tools but mechanical
tools
somebody had to make the anticathera
device and there probably wasn't just
one of them in antiquity
and the sort of a question of why didn't
that tradition
of sort of clockwork computer-like
things survive from antiquity and had it
survived
how would the history of computing be
different at the present time
but i i kind of think that archimedes
wouldn't have known what to do with
calculus if he had discovered it
at that time uh at least that would be
my my initial
take okay maybe one or two more
um
let's see
well the question here from monopoly
do you agree with the people that
physics and science has made minimal
progress in the last 25 years compared
to before
um you know all this
progress has all slowed down it's kind
of funny because i have
i have friends both who say there's
about to be a singularity there's
exponentially increasing progress
and other ones who say oh there's
nothing new under the sun
all progress has slowed down to a crawl
how can they both be right well
there are things like the number of
academic papers being written that's
increased
i don't think that's a great measure of
anything that's just a measure of the
number of people who are getting paid to
do science
and the dynamics of that uh sort of
institutional mechanism
i think the thing that is very confusing
is the following
in terms of sort of the rate of
expansion of knowledge and science and
so on
is this when there's something new on
the scene
new methodology new area of inquiry
new set of tools when there's something
new on the scene
there's a whole bunch of low-hanging
fruit to be picked and things happen
quite quickly
but when it's all been picked things
then happen quite slowly
now depending on the field and the
magnitude of the sort of tools and so on
that period of rapid growth may be a
variable length sometimes it'll be five
years sometimes it'll be 10 years
sometimes it might be 25 years sometimes
it may be even a bit longer than that
but it's a finite length and after that
period of rapid growth
is over a what you typically see
is a long grind for 50 years 100 years
before perhaps some particular area of
inquiry takes off again
with some with some new methodology new
tools and so on
so for example in physics back
in the uh heading towards the
the early part of the 1900s to 1920s and
so on
just tremendous growth a lot of low
hanging a lot of new methods new ideas
new mathematics
led to relativity quantum mechanics etc
and then again in the 1970s particularly
in particle physics
rapid growth but you know i was involved
in
that rapid growth period in the 1970s in
particle physics
and um the uh
it was a period of i don't know six
seven years
when it became clear that you could use
a bunch of methods from quantum field
theory
to do things and there was a lot of
interesting stuff to figure out
and by golly in six or seven years with
a whole bunch of people working on it
um and a bunch of it got figured out
and then all the easy stuff was done and
then it was a long grind
of doing much harder stuff and that's
very typical in all these different
fields so for example
in recent times we've seen machine
learning go through this cycle
machine learning had kind of originated
in i suppose the neural net idea in the
1940s
it had various little bursts of activity
in the 1960s
in the early 1980s hadn't really worked
out that well
then suddenly 2011 2012
bursts of interest in deep learning
things really take off
and there's a lot of low-hanging fruit
there's a lot of things that can be done
given that new methodology comparatively
easily
after and you know people are rushing to
do it and lots of interesting things get
done
and then the easy stuff gets done those
become
sort of method pieces of methodology
that sort of go into
a more engineering kind of mode and now
it's getting hard
and so that field you could say well you
know machine learning
uh it's you know it's proving that
nothing's nothing's going to be new in
the world because
machine learning is slowing down well
that's because it had its rapid growth
phase
because there was a really new and
important methodology one of the things
exciting to me right now
is with our physics project we're seeing
kind of a
a growth of what's possible in physics
that i don't think one's seen
in well close to 100 years actually i
think that
what one's seeing is a new methodology
new set of tools
a new kind of paradigm for making models
of things and only just understanding
that part about the kind of really
new paradigmatic approach to model
making but
that's allowing one to sort of
have this this rapid growth which i
think we're in the kind of just about
year one
of right now of of things that can now
be done in physics and actually it goes
beyond physics this kind of paradigmatic
approach
is something that applies to a bunch of
other fields too it's kind of a new
approach to modeling things i will say
that um uh
i've kind of been developing this view
of of kind of the
evolution of modeling in science that
really has
four phases for epochs
the first epoch being in antiquity when
the realization was
that gosh this whole universe with all
its diverse content
might be made of a small number of
different kinds of things
there might be polyhedra there might be
elements like fire and water and things
but in any case everything's made of a
small number of things and that was a
not an obvious observation but one that
that came from antiquity but in
antiquity there wasn't really a notion
of as i was saying before
of this kind of dynamics with time then
in 1600s there was kind of this idea of
using mathematics to model
the world and a notion of time where
time was a thing in a formula
where you could just say i'll pick my
time and it will be this
then in the early 1980s i would say
substantially through my efforts um kind
of this
idea of you can use programs as
fundamental models
of the natural world became started to
sort of come in
and that has different features in terms
of time for example computational
irreducibility
is a common thing you can run the
program that represents your model
and you can explicitly run it and find
out what it does but you can't expect to
jump ahead and say
oh this is what's going to happen at
this time without running through the
steps but that's sort of the next
paradigm
is this kind of idea of the sort of
computational paradigm
where you're doing these things where
you're sort of running programs to find
out what's going to happen in the world
what has come up from our physics
project is what i might call a
multi-computational paradigm
where you don't have just sort of a
single thread of time you're not just
looking at a program running
you're looking at something where you
essentially have a program but there are
many possibilities
at each step in the program and you have
this giant multi-way graph as we call it
of possible histories that can occur
and then what you realize is even to
know what's happened is not trivial
because you have this big collection of
threads
of different threads of time so to speak
different threads of of history
and you have to basically have some
notion of an observer
to decide how it is that you're sampling
this kind of multi-history
uh kind of structure and there's sort of
a precursor of that idea
that arises in relativity again actually
as we now understand it in quantum
measurement
and again that's kind of the one of the
core pieces
of what we're now understanding with our
physics project and that methodology
actually applies to a lot of fields
other than physics so that's kind of a
a piece it's part of the story of sort
of new methodology from our physics
project
and i fully expect that there will be
sort of a period of rapid growth
both in sort of what's possible in
physics now
and in what's possible in other fields
by using the somewhat different modeling
paradigm
and i think that's something where you
can expect to see rapid growth
and where it will look like oh my gosh
things are changing at such a rapid rate
and gradually everything will be figured
out there and again it will go into a
long hundred year grind
of making the next piece of progress but
we're still far away from that
so i think it's sort of a an interesting
thing that these
fields always go through these cycles of
you know new methodology rapid growth
sort of uh once the easy stuff has been
done
then a long grind until until a new
methodology is invented
and then things can start off again and
sometimes
there are fields where just nobody cared
about that before
the questions that were being asked just
nobody really cared like molecular
biology is a good example
where you know people just weren't that
interested in those aspects of biology
of looking at things at a molecular
scale and so on it became clear that was
very important
to understanding lots of things in
biology but that was kind of a new and
different field
similarly computer science another area
where
you know if you'd asked the early sort
of mathematicians who were kind of
buzzing around the early computing and
so on
you know is this going to be a whole
field of endeavor of of something to
study
they wouldn't have said it was i i
happened to when i was at the institute
for advanced study in princeton
some of the people who worked on von
neumann's computer project
uh came back to to talk about things and
some of the mathematicians
who'd been there at the time when that
project was happening
in the 1950s were also still around and
uh
there was kind of a bit of a bit of uh
sort of um
uh controversy because the
mathematicians when von neumann had died
had been very much of the
oh there's this nasty computer thing off
in this building let's just get rid of
all that that
equipment junk you know we just want to
do math which just requires pencil and
paper
and tom watson who was then uh ceo of
ibm
kindly offered to send a truck to come
and collect
the equipment from uh from the institute
to
take it off to i guess new york city
where ibm headquarters was at the time
and i think the um uh but any case i
the encounter between sort of the the
mathematicians
and the people who worked on the von
neumann computer project
i i guess i asked a bunch of questions
in this somewhat public forum
about which sadly probably wasn't
recorded because the answers were pretty
interesting
the um about uh kind of well you know
what did you guys
mathematicians really think would happen
with computers
back in the days of von neumann and
there was a quite
a a um a spirited discussion
of whether they had anticipated anything
significant
from computers or not but that was
another place where
kind of the question of computer science
so to speak was was there going to be
something to study there
now in my own efforts in my big book a
new kind of science
and my kind of studies of the
computational universe and studying what
simple programs do
there's a big question of is that a
thing worth doing well i think we have
very good evidence now and we have a few
decades of work
that have been done by people making use
of
the fruits of kind of the theoretical
study of simple programs in the
computational universe
less has been done on that than should
have been done it's really a field at
least as rich as pure mathematics in
fact
in some kind of definitional sense it's
vastly richer than pure mathematics
although probably less human than pure
mathematics less amenable to certain
kinds of human reasoning
than pure mathematics is but
nevertheless a a vast and fertile field
that has been uh much less explored than
it should have been
because people have still not really
understood as clearly as they should
have done
why one cares why is this like pure
mathematics
a thing that is worth studying so to
speak
and that's that's another issue in sort
of the developments of sciences is
people suddenly realize oh this is a
thing worth studying
let's go off and study it i think we're
seeing
today oh i think we can we can see
some some things with with quantum
computing for example
where people had studied including
myself even
bacco 40 years ago and more you know
had studied aspects of sort of how would
you bring quantum mechanics into
into sort of the idea of computing and
turing machines and all those kinds of
things
and it was like yeah you could do that
but at the time
people thought physics is not like
computing people thought physics
involves differential equations and real
numbers
and continua and things like that and
it's different from the story of physics
i didn't think that
i thought the two things were the same
from back from
from the early 1980s and at least i
thought that i didn't know about
fundamental physics how fundamental
physics would correspond
to computation but i did know and and
had very good reasons to believe that
kind of the
the overall mechanisms of physics kind
of the infrastructure of physics
was all about computation it was not
about mathematics
and that does seem to be what's what's
playing out but i think that the um
the thing at the time when one had
talked about like say quantum computing
it's like well there's the quantum stuff
that's physics
there's the computing stuff that's
computing and they're not really
connected
and so in more recent times people have
been very much trying to figure out you
know can we get quantum mechanical
effects
to do computing kinds of things and it's
kind of like well in the case of digital
electronic computers we have
this one idea of semiconductors it had
been a previous idea of vacuum tubes
before that
sort of vacuum tubes were a way of doing
computing then
they've given way to semiconductor
devices then
are the things that we can use next
things which somehow
are more obviously quantum mechanical
and then can we potentially leverage
effects which are quantum mechanical and
not classical i'm skeptical about that
last thing
but the idea of using other kinds of
foundations
for for computing that are you know
computing ultimately
computers are physical things so
ultimately the raw material is going to
come from physics
but exactly whether that physics is ions
in ion traps
or whether it's uh you know photons with
various kinds of interference patterns
or whether it's superconducting
uh interferometry devices
um with with quantized magnetic fields
and things
it's not clear which of these is is the
right kind of technology to use but the
fact that people have gotten interested
in that in recent years
is another one of this this could have
happened 30 years at least
earlier than it did it's just because
people weren't thinking about things in
in that same way and so it didn't happen
at that time
and i think uh there were a few yeah i
mean there were a few sort of
stimulating uh kind of theoretical uh
discoveries but it still could have
happened a lot earlier
let's see um
all right i'm going to just take a few
others some
um
commanders asked did i ever meet howard
georgia and shelley glacier yes i
i've known how george i i would say
fairly well for
for how long is it
40
44 years 45 years uh shelly gosh how i
i see from time to time i i don't i
don't know him terribly well
uh it's um howard is always um
a um a person who
um is a very cheerful person that
uh works at harvard and um
i know has done a lot of great stuff
with with mathematica and our wolfram
language
system um in in teaching physics at
harvard and so on and and doing research
there in fact howard is
is on my list of people who i should get
into i'm going to be starting a kind of
series of interview q a
sessions which are really me trying to
learn about things from other people
and um howard is somebody who's on my
list
to try and uh get to think about some
uh sort of phenomenological consequences
of our theory of physics
uh because he's good at that kind of
stuff and uh used to be fun talking to
him about that when i was in that
business back in the late 1970s
there's a question um
here uh
there's two two questions here there's a
question from james
did i get i did how did i get on with
john conway
do i have stories about him you know
john conway
who who sadly died um uh last year
um he and i john conway and i had many
similar
interests in terms of topics but
we were often interested in the same
topic but for utterly different reasons
i would say that john conway
was in some ways a a pure mathematician
who was very pure and in some ways
a very game-oriented mathematician
who is very much into kind of the
whimsical
and the kind of uh exotic so to speak
and i suppose my interests
we've both been interested in how
systems that are defined by simple rules
of various kinds
what those systems can do i've been
interested in that from a sort of
scientific almost natural science point
of view
understanding the complexity those
systems can produce
john conway i would say is more
interested in
uh well what can we figure out kind of
either as a isn't that
cute or how can we make sort of a piece
of pure mathematics out of these kinds
of things
i remember the first time i met john
conway
and um this is i think a story i can i
can reasonably tell
the uh was probably 1980
[Music]
maybe 19 between 1982 and 1984 i can't
remember exactly when
it was at a conference in the south of
france um
that uh uh
was about automata theory and um
uh sort of theory of things like
cellular automata finite automata
uh those kinds of things and uh i'm at
this lunch
with a bunch of mathematicians and john
conway
and john conway is asking people what's
what are their dates at birth and he's
then
using um uh
then saying oh i can tell you what day
of the week you were born
it's like okay and so he
spends you know i don't know 15 minutes
or something doing this
going round the table i don't know maybe
maybe it was a way of
of uh you know stealing people's
personal information i don't think it
was
eventually i'm like i just can't take
this any longer
this is ridiculous why are we sitting
here you know this is a bunch of people
who have all kinds of interesting things
to discuss about sort of sophisticated
math
and we're you know we're doing this
party trick
and i i so anyway the the lunch ends and
kind of i'm
going off with john conway and he's like
were people not impressed with that
and i'm like no that's just a party
trick
you know you're a serious mathematician
and you've got much more interesting
things to talk about
than that crazy party trick and i really
don't think he got it
i really think that he didn't make much
of a distinction
between that kind of party trick and
something about
sort of the the the far reaches of
number theory
or group theory or whatever which is
very strange to me
but anyway we had a a a long
conversation walking around the cliffs
around that um uh that that site
um talking about kind of things like
undecidability in mathematics he had a
rather different point of view
than mine about that and about how
common undecidability
and universality would be in in
mathematical systems but he worked on
i mean he was much later i was very
interested in sort of the history of
things like his game of life seller
automaton
and i had a long phone conversation with
him actually i recorded that
um and uh sometime i should put out the
recording of it
um and um it's the um
i have i have lots of these historical
recordings and um
eventually i'm going to get around to
organizing all of them
and putting them out there but the thing
i was interested in there was how did
john conway come to invent the game of
life cellular automaton
and he's you know there's a mythology
about oh it was this game it was based
on the game of go
et cetera et cetera et cetera and i'm
like you know really
and so i push quite hard and it took me
like two hours of drilling
and eventually he was telling me well
actually he had just become a he wanted
to get a job in cambridge he'd really
been a number theorist but the only
available job
was in logic and so he'd taken this job
in logic
and he wanted to do something that was
about logic
and so he got interested in the question
of how could you enumerate the recursive
functions
and he had also been reading stuff that
people like ulam had written about
cellular automata
and uh et cetera et cetera et cetera and
i was saying to him you know i just
don't get it you know you tell everybody
you invented this as a game but actually
you invented this
as a way to study infinite matrices
which is what ulam have been interested
in and a way to enumerate the recursive
functions
to me that's a lot more interesting than
the fact that you
invented it as some kind of game well
it was different different points of
view for different people
i think then there's a real mystery
about where the actual particular rules
for the game of life came from
because i drilled john conway for
a long time about that and he was
remarkably evasive
and i think he was i i suspect he did
not come up with the actual rules
the specific detailed rules that were
became the most popular ones
who cares you know the idea the context
as far as i'm concerned is the most
important thing
once you're down to well let's enumerate
possible rules which one is going to be
the most interesting one
that's an interesting thing to do and
it's a it's a piece of the story
but you have to have the whole idea of
setting the whole thing up in the first
place
and i think in his kind of very pure
mathematician way
it's like well if i didn't invent the
particular rules i shouldn't get credit
for it he was very very concerned about
about credit for things very very
concerned about that
and had a tremendous habit of sort of
trying to take things and sort of rename
them
uh to sort of attach himself to the to
the whole enterprise
um it's it's some uh in any case he
he um uh it was kind of a very funny
conversation because
because it was like uh you know well who
was involved in the
in the early days of game of life and
there was a person called steve bourne
who was in fact the person who invented
the bourne shell if you use eunuchs the
sh
shell is the bourne shell that's the
same steve bourne
um as uh programmed the uh the game of
life on a
pdp six or something um
and uh uh and then there was a
person called richard guy who died
recently at the age of 100 something
who was a uh kind of number theory and
games person
who um was involved and his son also was
involved
with um uh discovering the glider in the
game of life
and then anyway then things things went
on from there but but the
the the actual sort of early origin
story is still a bit shrouded in mystery
and i've been planning actually to go
and try and drill that some more and
there's a
there's a chap who i think was involved
in it who um we did some sort of
interviews a few years ago
with some people who are involved in
kind of discovering
uh interesting behavior in the game of
life
um as sort of a model for how
engineering progress can happen
and uh been meaning to piece together
some more of that
um it's uh um
oh there are all kinds of questions here
about um i could i could tell you lots
more about john conway i think
um i was um uh
a woman named siobhan roberts wrote his
a good biography of him
i was quite amused because she
kind of wanted to interview me about
about john conway and i i
i think my first statement was you know
my relationship to your subject was
complicated
and uh she quotes that line in her book
and has a quite accurate and rather
rather charming few pages about um
some more detailed um description of of
um
of of my interactions with john conway
but um i would say that the
the most notable thing is that interest
in in some of the same topics
but just completely different
motivations for being interested in them
and um uh and and so on
so um
well we should probably wrap up here i
need to go off and do something else
there's a question about carl sagan here
i
i never met carl sagan unfortunately um
although
for various reasons i was very curious
oh how did this happen
um
somehow from his widow i got a copy of
his cv
which is interesting mostly for being
unbelievably thick
um i think i was interested i can't even
remember why that happened
we were exchanging mail about something
and um
it's just interesting because i think
carl sagan was a very
committed kind of popularizer of science
and really sort of played all of the
all of the venues and his cv is just an
amazing collection of different sorts of
uh
uh of places and and uh and so on where
he was uh kind of taking the message of
science and so on
um kind of kind of interesting to see
that
all right i think we should wrap up here
for today
so a bit of a uh um a romp through a
variety of different topics
um so we had a number of questions here
that
look like they'll be a good seed for
next time
so thanks for